we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p the number
is available 24 hours a day you can call
anytime people do call at any time of
day here's a voicemail that came in
about donald trump's sort of space
military that he wants to develop hey
David I was just calling man Donald
Trump has mentioned a couple times now
this idea of a space force and I just
have to say that I think it's a
fantastic idea think about how that will
strengthen the idea of American
exceptionalism if we have the first ever
space force sure we may have to allocate
the entire discretionary budget to the
military but do we really need education
or healthcare anyway I just want to say
that I think it's a great idea and I
wondered on just what your thoughts were
on the space floor thanks David yeah we
talked yesterday during my interview
with David Weintraub about the concerns
around the corporatization of space
travel or specifically of going to Mars
there's another element which is even
worse which is the militarization of
space and space exploration as we've
talked about before there's very little
sort of legal infrastructure as to who
owns stuff in space there's something
called like the moon treaty or something
like that
I believe it's from the late 70s and it
attempts to outline sort of some
parameters but this is gonna be a big
deal and I've talked about sort of
waiting around gleefully for when we are
able to capture a asteroid that is
completely made of diamonds and all of a
sudden everybody on this planet who
thinks they've got this really valuable
diamond will realize oh wait a second
these things don't really have inherent
value why did I why did I spend 12 grand
on this thing for for getting engaged I
do look forward to that
but I am also very very concerned about
how quickly anytime there are financial
interests somewhere you will have the
use of force brought in to backup and
protect those financial interests so
while I think it's nuts that Donald
Trump's focus when it comes to space
exploration does seem to be a space
force a space military whether Trump
brings it up or not as soon as
monetizing space really becomes a thing
defending those monetization resources
is immediately going to become a thing
whether it's Trump who mentions it or
not so I think Trump is of course
focused on the wrong thing when it comes
to space but there's a lot of people who
are already thinking along these lines
we have a great bonus show for you today
john mccain has said he does not want
donald trump at his funeral according to
what friends of his are telling the
White House the we now have learned
about an attorney general who is vowing
to break up immigrant families that are
crossing the border illegally and we
also are going to talk about Donald
Trump urging a West Virginia West
Virginia voters to vote against a former
coal executive who went to prison all of
those stories and more are on today's
bonus show which you can access two ways
number one become a member at join
pakman.com number two become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show both
methods will give you instant access to
the world-famous bonus show we will
speak to you then